A key aspect to connecting your genome
into populations all over the world, often
includes understanding allelic distribution. Remember, unlike a
disease that spreads laterally from person to
person, alleles are spread across generations from
parents to offspring to offspring to offspring.
Of course this is an inherently slower
process and it changes depending on reproductive
habits of various populations. We learned a bit about
this in lesson six, when we discussed natural selection
and genetic drift playing a role. Take this map
for the allele of lactase persistance. Now, it may be
a little hard to see here but we have
an outline of Africa, Europe, Asia, Oceania and some
of the Pacific islands. We also have an inset
here of Central America and South America. Now each circle
represents a snapshot currently of the prevalence of
the T allele or the C allele. Remember the
T allele correlates with lactase persistence. And the
C allele correlates with lactase non persistence. And you
can see just looking at this map each
circle from each spot represents the prevalence of that
allele in that region, in that given population. So
although allelic frequencies and distributions can change over time,
we can get individual snapshots at any given moment. And
at this particular moment you can look at this map and
see the regions where lactase persistence would be prevalent based
on the prevalence of the T allele. And where lactase non-persistence,
would be prevalent based on the prevalence of the C
allele or the darkened region of the circle. Now selection pressures
in milk drinking populations. Really only, maybe 5,000 years ago, have
resulted in the rapid spread of the C allele throughout the
world. The T allele. So if I tell
you that I am lactase persistant, which regions
of the world would you assume that I
do not share ancestry? Now there are multiple answers
to this question, so make sure you check
any and all that apply. And if you're absolutely
terrible with geography, I've actually labelled the different
regions or answers here in the map for you.